foreign
California Ryan how can we help
hi good afternoon guys
um I'm in fifty thousand dollars in
student debt and I grab and I've been
looking for a job but no one has hired
me what are the next steps I should do
well you just keep going you don't quit
so what have you been trying to get
hired to do
I graduated from University 18 months
ago and when I first graduated I I go on
my Excel spreadsheet type in like all
the student gifts that went in and then
I'm just like okay first goal I'm gonna
go try to seek a job and then that was
from January of 2022 till now it's been
18 months been applying for jobs been on
active on LinkedIn zip recruiter indeed
been applying for jobs no one calls me
for interviews okay and all right either
that or have been ghosted and then I'm
just like initially I was thinking like
okay if there's student loan forgiveness
what's to happen twenty thousand might
be forgiven yeah but if not I need to be
serious about this plan what should I do
before I make my first payment in
October yeah all right so Ryan uh
there's gonna I'm gonna give you two
pieces of advice here I want George to
weigh in as well
um
you should have been working the entire
time it was it is it the job that you've
been trying to get probably not I don't
know if it was attached to your major I
never got an answer from you as to what
type of jobs you're looking for we'll
get to that in a minute but you need to
be working we are in a fantastic gig
economy now if you've not heard that
phrase it just means we live in an
economy where you can work whether
you're driving delivery from one of the
major Rideshare companies
or you're doing something locally or
you're doing freelance work the gig
economy is I'm a private contractor
essentially I set my own hours I come
and go and there is a lot of opportunity
in our economy for those type of jobs
they're also right now we're seeing a
tremendous amount of of jobs that are
available in the 15 to 20 an hour range
maybe doing something menial maybe not
doing something that you want to do
but it is money nonetheless and you've
been sitting on the sidelines waiting
for someone
to discover you I've been doing rights
from the side I've been doing right here
on this time oh you didn't tell us that
is that how you've been paying the bills
for the last 16 months
correct I've been uh paying the bills
for the last time how much money are you
making rent
uh per week uh per weekend I am work
making between 500 to 600 what are you
doing during the week
during the week I'm just waking up by
nine and then just keep on looking at my
laptop and just applying for jobs Ryan
until someone reaches out to me and
interviews me right that's not enough
you need to be working full time you
need to be working 40 hours a week and
knocking out that debt
you you could have knocked a huge chunk
of that debt out working 40 hours was
just a retail job but whatever it is
what you're doing right now is not
working and you are essentially playing
the the professional Lottery by going on
LinkedIn sending out messages sending
out resumes and you are a nameless
faceless person and I hate that for you
but that's the process we live in right
now where everything's Ai and if you
apply for a job if you don't have a
relationship connection
to that company
to say hey let me tell you about Ryan I
know Ryan I've known Ryan since he was a
baby or blah blah blah blah blah
whatever it is you've got to make real
personal connections at these at these
companies to get yourself an interview
you're not even getting to the interview
phase and then when you are getting
there nothing's happening because you
haven't stood out prior to the process
or in the game so I'm going to give you
some free resources I'm also going to
give you a couple of paid resources
towards the end I'll tell you what those
are but but you you need to understand
that right now your goal is is you got
to get out of the dull drums you got to
get out of this rut
where you're just sitting around getting
rejected day in and day out hearing
nothing but crickets and only doing
Rideshare on the weekend
you could be paying off this this
student loan debt George how much could
he I mean you know the numbers crunch
the numbers how much could he be paying
off uh every month how much could he
have paid off if he's working full-time
while he's trying to find that that that
that placement in the field he wants to
be in well a lot of these as you know
these Rideshare jobs you can easily make
20 bucks an hour delivering food
groceries people packages and so let's
even call that 20 bucks an hour 40 hours
a week that's 800 bucks a week so you
start multiplying that out you said you
don't pay rent right
no I don't pay rent so you're talking
over three grand a month that could have
been going towards paying off these
student loans during the pause so that
you're not on this predicament where now
student loan payments are coming back
and you still are unemployed
so I would get to work ASAP even if it's
not the dream job you could almost be
out of the fifty thousand dollars of
debt is what we're getting at you could
be very close to have paid that off
just doing what George did with those
numbers so what field are you trying to
get into
um so I've been trying to be a data
analyst or a financial analyst because I
have more into data analytics and
graduate Finance okay so you got the
degree you had a good GPA all that stuff
correct sir all right so you realize
that you're gonna have to make some
personal connections you got to have
some people calling people on your
behalf that you've already played it the
way that most people try to play it and
then they get they get discouraged so
I'm going to give you a book called The
Proximity principle all right and I want
you to read it or I'll give you the
audio version if that's your preference
and it's a deep dive on how to make
connections because the right people
Ryan plus the right places bring me
opportunity they show up at your door do
you understand that formula
yes sir yeah when I'm around the right
people they'll make good connections for
me when I'm in the right places I meet
more of the right people and I start
getting opportunities you got to get
really serious about this but you're
going to cut your time that you just
been sitting there submitting resumes
and all that and you're going to get
busy and you're gonna get some momentum
and paying off this debt and uh and then
you from there you're gonna feel a
little bit more juice because you're not
just sitting there looking at that
student loan payment come in and nothing
happening you need some wins right now
and paying off that student loan by
working 40 50 maybe 60 hours a week for
a while would be great and then Making
Connections you're driving and when
you're not driving you're meeting with
people George that's the play and with
no rent I mean let's knock this thing
out while you have that sweet deal
happening yep so hang on the line we'll
get you a copy of the proximity
principle that'll help you there